what exactly happened after Edward
Norton made the Incredible Hulk with
marble why was a respected star kicked
out of Hollywood's most successful
franchise from paycheck problems to
behind-the-scenes struggles here are the
real reasons Edward Norton was fired
from the MCU
it's widely known that Norton is a guy
who likes to call the shots even when
he's not the one in charge he showed up
on the set of red dragon one day with
new lines he'd written for himself in
Anthony Hopkins when he refused to star
in the remake of The Italian Job a film
he was contractually obligated to do
paramount had to threaten a lawsuit
before he accepted the role and perhaps
most infamously he used his a-list clout
to re-edit American History X a move
that infuriated director Tony K of
course Marvel Studios has had its fair
share of control-freak moments too when
execs didn't like Edgar Wright's vision
for ant-man or patty Jenkins take on
Thor the dark world the studio cut ties
with those directors Marvel also gave
Joss Whedon a hard time during Avengers
age of Ultron with Whedon having to
fight tooth and nail to keep certain
scenes in the movie in other words
Edward Norton is an immovable object and
Marvel Studios is an unstoppable force
when the two crashed together things got
really messy really fast once shooting
was finished on the Incredible Hulk a
civil war broke out between Marvel and
Norton after watching the film studio
executives decided that they wanted more
action and more excitement in a shorter
runtime this didn't sit well with Norton
who had previously been allowed to make
his own considerable rewrites to the
script Norton was especially upset
because he thought he was going to have
more say in the creative process
according to Deadline the actor had been
promised tremendous involvement in
access to the final product but Marvel
wasn't too keen on Norton's
contributions and they chopped out many
of the scenes he'd written flashback
sequences that gave Banner more depth
were tossed by the wayside and an
opening scene in which Norton's
character tries to end his own life was
left on the cutting room floor while
Norton was hoping for a more
introspective film that ran around 140
minutes The Incredible Hulk became a
run-of-the-mill
action flick that was just 112 minutes
long Norton was upset and frustrated and
subsequently took a backseat when
came to promoting the movie
in 2010 shortly before the stars of The
Avengers assembled at the San Diego
comic-con MCU Godfather Kevin Feige who
had originally shown interest in having
Norton joined the Avengers released a
statement signaling that the short-lived
Norton era was over in the statement
Feige said our decision is definitely
not based on monetary factors but
instead rooted in the need for an actor
who embodies the creativity and
collaborative spirit of our other
talented cast members I'm for you
basically Feige said that Norton was
getting the boot because he wasn't a
team player according to Deadline one
marble insider described Norton as a
wolf in the henhouse and based on his
alleged behavior on films like Red Dawn
and American History X it's easy to see
why Marvel might have been eager to part
ways
although Feige said money had nothing to
do with Norton's firing from the
Avengers Norton's agent Bryan sword
strum beg to differ
according to sword strum Norton had been
looking forward to working with Joss
Whedon and the other cast members of the
Avengers apparently the actor was
enthusiastic about starring in such a
big blockbuster but according to sword
strim Marvel let him go for purely
financial reasons infuriated with Feige
sword strim said the producers comments
were mean-spirited
not to mention unprofessional
disingenuous and clearly defamatory
while sword strums rant didn't exactly
do Norton any good it did raise a few
eyebrows among the Marvel fanbase and
made some people question the studio's
version of events
Norton's own public opinion on the issue
has evolved over the years since he left
the MCU in 2008 when the Incredible Hulk
drama became public
Norton gave a statement to Entertainment
Weekly blaming the media for twisting
the facts and blowing everything out of
proportion but in June 2010 after
telling his Facebook followers that he
wouldn't be starring in The Avengers
Norton wrote I sincerely hoped it could
happen and be great for everyone but it
hasn't turned out as we all hoped in a
2011 interview with the independent
Norton then said that Marvel's decision
to let him go had nothing to do with him
playing nice with others he instead
claimed that it was a flat-out business
decision motivated entirely
by money finally in a 2014 interview
with NPR Norton changed his tune again
he explained my feeling was that I
experimented and experienced what I
wanted to I really really enjoyed it but
Norton also said he was glad to have
parted ways with the MCU as being part
of the Marvel machine would have
required years of commitment and might
have caused him to miss out on roles in
Birdman and Moonrise Kingdom Jiminy
Cricket he flew the coop for a while it
seemed like the war between Norton and
Marvel was over in July 2018 Norton took
part in a Comedy Central Roast of
legendary action star Bruce Willis when
it was his turn at the Mike Norton poked
and prodded at his Hollywood friend but
he also loved a few bombs at the studio
that he believed had screwed him over
referencing Willis's tough-guy
filmography Norton quipped I tried to be
like you I did a big action movie called
The Incredible Hulk you know what went
wrong I wanted a better script and he
didn't finish there Norton went on to
say I thought we should try to make one
Marvel movie that was as good as the
worst Christopher Nolan movie but what
the hell was I thinking it just goes to
show that no matter how much time may
have passed Norton still got a little
anger in him check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite actors are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]